hi my name is Michael hang I'm the host
of the Opie land you have found yourself
on a Friday evening at an esports panel
at PAX Oh have you guys had a good day
packs today because how lung capacities
not good I understand I feel the exact
same way so let's like just get straight
into it shall we I'm gonna becoming a
professional eSports play out with these
are not the same order but team carbon
Wendell is closest to me assignments
with a pepper Marcus oh good yeah Nathan
Ricky's Mott and Jax Pont Iberia are all
here ladies gentleman can I ask you to
give round reports and welcome our
panelists so we're gonna be chatting
about a few things today a very very
brief history of eSports in hose we're
gonna be talking about how to become a
professional eSports athlete we're also
going to be taking your questions so
they're gonna be mics here towards the
end we'll get into that so do think
about what you might like to ask but
let's kick things off with a picture of
PAX 2013 let me start with you guys the
panel who was here at 2013 any of you
Jake Schwimmer Jake how has packs
changed in three years well I was in a
crowd in 2013 so it was really actually
huge in 2013 because it was the first
right event that we'd ever put in and
you know so big people standing around I
mean it was much more convention style
there were no seats or anything like
that just lots of people crowded around
and lots of lanyards being handed out by
Atlus and myself so it was a little bit
different back then and when you were
here in 2013 what capacity were you here
as a plan is your mic working too many
mics onstage so maybe we can just yeah
mine's working we bring that across yeah
everyone so um you know here's a player
during 2013 I know you representing
exile 5 I don't think they exist in
League of Legends anymore right there in
the OPR samus what happens in the
Challenger Series sorry I don't
yeah I've played for them and then
little did I know but it would start a
long tradition as may never winning
anything impacts Logitech booth today if
you've been losing today as well yeah
yeah
we won't the IWC 2013 it Gamescom
there's just some images I'll just
scroll through quickly winter 2014 Tim
carbon Wendell I see you in that
beautiful picture there
in the bottom I guess left-hand corner
tell us a bit about what you were doing
in 2014 yeah that was the last time I
felt happiness 2014 European final 2015
which is last year with anyone here at
Luna Park last year for the IPL final
yes very people yes I guess you know
you're in Melbourne you know travel it's
fine
and this is your final 2016 I know three
of you with a trapeze with your the the
OPL final 26 I was there as a spectator
unfortunately unfortunately yeah because
these are we had that we had this sort
of I don't know if you guys have how
deeply you follow OPL I see any would
otherwise why you but we hope it was
Chiefs and legacy because the sort of El
Clasico Jack and I were there on the
analyst desk but I feel like that's just
the history of I've caught you all up
you up to speed it's fine let's move
along so I guess what we're talking
about is how we move from 2013 to 2016
and that's 2017 what we're gonna be
doing some questions so this is training
regimes so I guess I'll start with the
pro players on and then I'll ask Jack
for commentary afterwards down the line
something with you Tim what is a day
like for you in terms of a trainer what
is a week like for you in terms of
training because it is a full-time job
yeah there's a full-time job at least it
was for us off every IPL team this year
but it definitely was for our guys
including myself average week for us
usually involves at least one opl game
which was I think on a Monday or Tuesday
and every single other day is scrims and
so like you
we play on average six hours worth of
screams and then probably I'd say
roughly around another six hours worth
of solid cubed about ten to fourteen
hours a day
there's outliers some people practice a
lot more some people practice a lot less
that's a usual day for us
screams solar cue a lot of odd review
sometimes we do media stuff
team-building activities on the weekend
we like to do those I think those are
really important kind of breaking the
week up one of the big things about
living in the gaming house is um you
kind of get into a rhythm which is both
good and bad because when you're in the
rhythm like you often find that you're
playing really well but at the same time
it's easy to lose track of time and I
find that the more breaks you give the
better you're able to kind of categorize
what you've learned and not that you
know you play for three weeks straight
and then you start doing the same
mistakes you were doing three weeks ago
mmm because you now found a new problem
that you need to try and solve yeah here
taking on breaks off - screams - kinda
stand in the circle that side really
helps to break up like the monotony of
screams right dude I'm all about
standing outside like there's nothing
worse than sitting than playing a scrim
and then just sitting there like you
need you need to well I you need to get
outside I think I think that's good
advice for anyone probably especially
some of us here because I'm wondering
I'm one of you
but getting getting outside is really
important I think especially just
getting some Sun like so many so many of
the guys just literally do not want to
get up and it's I don't know about what
you guys do we're pretty much kept like
pent up in more or less like prison in
just forced to play because we have to
come firstly free to boot I mean like
Malusi and that's punishment enough
right so yeah yeah so we were a stimulus
aim was sort of well this year at least
we were part we didn't have the team
else so it was more I mean that players
were technically still full-time but
it's still playing online
we saw didn't have the luxury of in our
to arm you know bodrov you in person and
all that stuff so I was more just over
teamspeak which was sort of our virtual
communication
office so likely to change in 2017 for
you guys
yes ISO next year will be as with most
of the teams we're moving in to team
houses to accommodate for the live opl
matches that are in right studio in
Piemonte sydney so so yeah it's
definitely gonna spice up to go pal hope
y'all a bit cuz you know there's a lot
more stuff you can do there so I'm it's
going to be very exciting and finally
Jake you had a very short career as a
coach of the Chiefs about what your kind
of role was there before you kind of
full-time committed to Casting no just
let me try that one at the end I don't
know why these mics aren't working hello
Hey all right cool so as a coach it was
really strange back then because as
repiy was kind of alluding to a lot of
it was done over teamspeak which is hard
to coach players over ten speak honestly
because it's very hard to get respect in
a virtual environment first of all yeah
I mean even when you got you know in
between screams you just have you know
you're trying to coach the team and then
you have the players on Twitter like
straightaway not listening not taking in
you know we have to say so you know in
person and the team else is sort of like
you know you can see they're like you
know you can see this person who's on
Twitter I'll say for example Jake would
be you know trying to tell him what you
know they're meant to be doing in that
game instead of on yeah and that was the
other thing that like we really
struggled with is there's a big
difference now between coaching and
between being an analyst and I think
that I was a pretty good example of
someone that was a good analyst but
maybe not a good coach because as a
person you know it can be pretty blunt
and direct with some of my criticisms
which people find entertaining on
casting but not very much so if you're
playing on a team so I think that one of
the biggest challenges that a lot of the
guys face going into gaming houses and
I'm sure teams will face next year as
well is you have to find smart people to
surround you came in and you know the
contagion can point out you know the
most accurate mathematical way to play
the game but then you also need people
that like I guess this is why I really
respect carbon because he's one of the
best at it that is a good people person
you know is able to rally
you know able to keep morale high and
stuff like that so I really do think
that they're two different roles within
the system and when I was a coach it
just didn't exist that way so that was
one of the biggest challenges honestly
of you know taking a team of 17 to 19
year old guys back then through
professional video games it was pretty
hard when you never win raising morale
becomes a pretty important skill time
yeah well speaking of rivalries you know
so just say just so you guys know what
happening what's happening in the
audience the slides were made for a
panel about eSports and now we're trying
to focus I think you're probably more
interested in how to become a
professional eSport
right is that kind of the vial I'm
getting from the title of the panel yeah
you don't care do you most of you are
here because your bus doesn't come till
7:00 that's fine well then and speaking
of never winning no money if I get to do
it you don't get to make fun of me only
I get to make fun of Calvin I can
probably kick this one off however
because the rivalry that was born out of
winter it's probably like one of the
best rivalries I've ever seen for those
who don't know Chiefs used to win
everything they'll attend immunity back
then used to they just picked up they
just picked up a superstar coach in
myself going very confident into the
final where they hadn't dropped it game
I don't think and then a cheeky team
called avant-garde ascension absolutely
destroyed them over five games and
pretty much cross with his hopes and
dreams
absolutely when they strung it out and
let him you know really feel that burn
from then even though it has been in
recent history a little bit more
one-sided and I say that with as much
respect as possible I'm sure every
single time their Chiefs do have a look
across the roof to legacy they do
remember those faithful games back in
2014 know
I mean I mean how does it play Simon as
someone who has been involved in this
rivalry for a number of years now how
does it I mean is is you say no jokingly
though right like you like legacy are
sort of the team for you guys to beat in
in in many respects right yeah so how
you guys do it in terms of your
preparation yeah I think it was actually
a really important lesson like losing to
legacy on in 2014 two years ago now and
anyone laughs are you Jesse after
laughing and it was important because
going into it like I think everyone on
the team pretty much felt untouchable
and we felt and no one was really
putting in a lot of effort at the time I
think because we actually thought that
we couldn't lose and I think it was like
a massive wake-up call to us to you know
stop putting effort in again and then
the next one we are placed worth than we
did in that one so I guess it wasn't
exactly the wake-up call we needed but
it was a start and then from there I
think we just kind of tried to build on
our strengths and never let that happen
again is it something that's kind of
organic or is it something you guys
decide as a team we're gonna take these
people we're gonna take these people
down okay how do these things evolve for
you
I don't know if he'll rival recent like
generally I don't know the answer but I
know for us at least was more organic
we never yeah like coming into it we
know we're not it wasn't like aiming for
them or anything like that and we didn't
have anything against them in fact uh I
think most of us were friends with most
of them at the time you say were in past
tense
no at the time and there was no real
rivalry and I think part of that was
they didn't really see us as such and we
didn't really think that we were that
good either to be honest yeah we were
just there for the fun but we managed to
win and then and then it kind of became
a thing where you know a lot of people
were saying oh it was a fluke or
whatever and and we didn't follow this
the scene too closely before that so I
wasn't really even aware that they were
supposedly that good and then the next
and they win yeah that was pretty much
it yeah I'm not it no exaggeration and
then it was more than aftermath the kind
of career the rivalry for me and then
you know the next couple finals after
that definitely cemented it all right
let's move on now to a quick rundown the
actually sorry can I just continue on
that yes yeah so I just look for some
more shade yeah yeah no not so much of
that but I just remember why so after we
won in 2014 and we were still on
friendly terms we thought at least on
friendly terms with with the Chiefs like
we didn't have anything against them
like I said we were there for fun and we
won and it was it was a lot of fun for
us at least maybe we didn't realize you
know just how hurt they were but we boot
came to medially afterwards and the
Chiefs like just hit need to help us out
help us prepare for wildcards because it
was still a really new thing it was the
first year that actually had their own
server so we were super new and everyone
wanted to see us do well so Chiefs fire
to bootcamp against us after thing
anyway they spanked us basically for
that week they spent the entire week
spanking us and then just before we left
just before we left I'll never forget
one of the Chiefs players as we live we
said our goodbyes we just spent a week
of training with these guys one of the
Chiefs players turned to me and said as
he was walking away know this but said
are you guys suck
do you want to are you gonna keep that
secret yeah no I'm not gonna say I'm
never gonna say that was but um but one
of the one of the Chiefs players said
that and and it was kind of at that
moment where I was like all right you
know what I look forward to playing you
again think I'm want to ask is well Jake
actually from the perspective of the
pastor and someone who's trying to craft
narratives throughout a season the
rivalries do you feel like it is good to
lean on them and to hype it up or the or
do you feel like you know each game
should be equal and special in your
beautiful mind no way yeah no they're
definitely special I think that we
genuinely had well what you have to do
is you have to take an even table look
in because what happened when we first
started the OPL as well is it i guess he
fell away slightly though the third best
team and then Nathan's team the
direwolves jumped up and challenge for
that final as well so what we kind of
had is this like three-way tie so we
have what I call Anzac Day all the time
which is legacy versus Chiefs but then
you also had during the regular season
in the last couple of years dire wolves
beating both of them so it created this
really dark or like the two top dogs and
then a dark horse story and from a
narrative point of view I mean it helps
out a lot the game's self-promote I mean
the players genuinely feel like they
want to go in and I'm sure Nathan can
speak to going into every single game
against these two guys as underdogs and
winning a fair share of them as well so
I think that having those kind of
rivalries in those kinds of especially
when they're in sportsmanship matter
actually really helps out and you know
it helps me deal with your point of view
as I'm sure you guys are aware I'm sure
you guys tune in when legacy and Chiefs
play each other also helps from a caster
point of view because uh you know we get
to see how much it means to the guys and
you get to see pretty much the two three
best teams and oceania going at it so it
really does help that our top teams have
stayed on top for so long and have
stayed competitive with each other for
so long when it looked like it was going
to be dominant I mean at the end of the
day Chiefs have won their fair share
it never really has come all that easy
apart from that one sorry I mean in
terms of robberies it's always been like
your Chiefs legacy and then like dolls
aways as Jake said that you know the
Dark Horse I just sort of caught more
the middleman you know it's sort of like
sort of friends with both sides you know
could we have X players on both teams so
that's sort of how I look at it there
but you know the rivalry has always come
about because they're in the finals
right so if you happen to be playing you
know with each other in the finals a lot
and save for us a legacy was a semi
finals for three splits and then Chiefs
was the last ones last time you found on
which we unfortunately lost to bad arm
but yeah you know so we sort of have a
rivalry we've sort of just trying to
fight for the top spot really from
Darwin's perspective yeah all right well
let's move on to spreadsheets you know I
guess the kind of key point is this is
in many ways one of one of your revenue
streams that allows you guys to do this
full-time right so from a player
perspective do you like how much in os--
because the organizations are small and
that would be in EU or the US you guys
would have to end up doing a lot of this
stuff yourselves where otherwise it
wouldn't have an organization behind you
to do it especially the view carbon
right yeah mine's a little bit
self-inflicted though because you're a
control freak or because maybe it kind
of ended up that way and then I kind of
found myself in a position where I
didn't feel like oh yeah anyone else
would do a better job really yeah myself
so I thought well I'll just do it then
but now look it is um it is really
important I think the work that the org
I don't think it's a surprise really
that that arson Chiefs well and and one
other team were the only teams that God
that God no sorry I'm talking at the
Hellions not identify although maybe I
should have anyway no no so there's only
three gaming houses this year and I
don't I think um
that the oil plays a really big part in
that and yeah and it's a really obvious
example of a way that org can have a
direct influence on your performance and
I mean when you have a look at these
three teams especially I mean the reason
that this becoming so iconic is that you
have like things like the assuming house
that legacy you know through a big day
for and then you have the LG launched
with direwolves and their faces are all
over pax at the moment Sybil's double
dip there somehow Ruby I don't know how
that the logitech booth I mean with
chips all over it at the moment so I
think that it is a good example of you
know how partnership does come into it
you know whilst they are sponsors like
if the relationship goes both ways I
mean I'm sure you can speak a lot to it
as well at the moment Nathan seems that
you're going through it yeah well I mean
obviously sponsors are a big part of you
know any sport you know traditional
sports sponsors driver a lot of the
revenue stream in eSports is more so the
sponsors rather than the traditional
sports but um yeah well get in you know
say a mainstream brand like LG for
example that we had sort of a lot of
tension not just to our team but sort of
eSports in general so um say it was
really good for us um but yeah it's sort
of same with Tim like I think Tim it's
to be hard to frame so obviously as a
player and you know sort of manages the
sponsorships and the team side but for
me I stopped playing due to you know
focusing on that stuff so um so yeah
it's it's it's obviously gonna get
bigger over the next couple couple years
but um but yeah definitely sponsorships
are a big part of any opl team Jurgen
Sanne I was just gonna say that maybe
you can take something from Ricky there
and start managing your team properly
instead of plan alright I think I need
to be sitting in between how good i
would be if i didn't have to run it
unlock the potential super Sayan common
all right so I think we should now this
is kind of that we're gonna end before
we go into questions and I really want
to dive into the path to being a pro so
all four of you have managed to kind of
score I guess dream jobs for you right
playing video games and talking about
video games professionally let me start
by asking just quickly down the line
starting with you Tim did you like I
know eSports has kind of come out of
nowhere for people our age but at what
point did you kind of think that this is
something you wanted to do for your life
or for your career have you realized
that yeah I'm not sure at that moment
yet in the back of my mind I still think
about what you know when I hear the word
career I think about you know what I'll
be doing in ten years time 20 is time
and you know if I'll be jungling I don't
know probably not but I know for me yeah
I mean I didn't even know what eSports
was I had no idea it existed I had never
heard of it I played video games for fun
I guess but then I didn't even really
play online games like how I was
Nintendo kid growing up I just played
like Zelda and like Super Smash Brothers
and that with my friends like I never
really took it seriously and then League
was just something that I picked up
during uni and yeah yeah I don't know I
was just doing it for fun in them I
happened to be good at it I suppose and
I got invited to play on the team and I
thought well never done that before but
it sounds like fun it could be good and
we did that and and really I think the
only reason I ever found out what
eSports was was because I found a little
bit of success in it early I think you
know if if I had lost in 2014 why don't
when I first started playing I probably
will just stopped in and and I don't
know what I would have done gone to work
I suppose yeah well I mean I'd finish
uni I finished I graduated University
just before I started playing just
before my first tournament and so I was
actually working I was doing placement
after uni though at a Regional Health
Center I did health science for those
who are interested so I was working at
original health
Sena and I kinda had to choose you know
because they offered to keep me on what
I wanted to do because I couldn't travel
I couldn't travel all the time and work
full-time so I thought well we'll give
these four to crack us about because I
was playing Starcraft a pretty high
level and was never committed to but was
thinking about moving to Korea and
having the conversation with your
parents about hey I want to play video
games full-time and just trying to
explain that to them is terrifying but
with that my dad was like that's not a
real job I was like don't worry if
Starcraft doesn't work out dad I've got
a back-up plan stand-up comedy all right
it's gonna be fine
I've got to sort it all you must have
trusted you because that's a pretty
funny joke yeah
Jenny's 17 my comedy special comes down
the ibc please watch it all right
ATM tonight me day Karen Bob Simon let
me ask you as well about your road from
from from being I guess a casual player
to kind of being captain of a an
internationally touring eSports team you
you you just came back from Paris you're
about to go to Oakland for I am like how
what point do you kind of commit to
wanting to do this full-time why first
of all like offered to join a team back
when he didn't have a server and it was
I think yeah at the time I like like all
the players now I've moved on and
they've been they've retired and I
remember getting offered and I was just
thinking like I just thought to myself
oh yeah this is this is pretty cool like
I'll just do this and then just continue
on with the rest of my life and
everything and then slowly as a sports
like developed in Australia I had to
commit more and more time to it at the
end it was this year I was the first
year where I stopped kind of studying as
well as well as playing and committed to
it full-time and it was only really this
year that I really kind of considered
myself a professional gamer just because
it was the first year that I actually
had to sacrifice something to in order
to pursue it and it wasn't like an easy
choice for anything and I told my
parents as well that like
they uh have you know I had a backup
monetary I wasn't stand up there what
was your backup I was just like going
back to you maybe it's not yeah maybe
it's just as bad as your what was your
parents reaction when you were like I
want to play video games um my mom
actually my mom and dad they did that
thing where they were like oh no year
like we support you but then but like
this I had like really dour expressions
we supported you I guess just like I'm
just a disappointment no I think I think
that they it was mainly like when I
started winning in like money started
coming in that they they saw it as like
like semi viable and then being like
relatively successful in it as well has
helped push that agenda though sure and
so they're they're fairly happy I think
as long as I do go back to uni
eventually eventually be a mature aged
student who asked questions during class
I can't wait to be though just all the
time you know they're they're quite
happy with it um Nathan you founded at a
yeah well I mean it's pretty simple for
me so as you know everyone in this room
you know we sort of started off playing
games and eSports wasn't really a thing
as Tim was saying but back in our day I
sort out a different path I was sort of
forced into legal legends so I was
playing a couple of other games at a
very high level and or are you playing
so back in the day would have Warcraft
Arena was like a big thing so I was
almost a Rank 1 gladiator which is like
the highest highest level back in those
days and I was sort of playing with
Americans and I don't moved to another
game cookie walls too and there was
meant to be like sort of the next
biggest eSports so I started following
eSports all right around legal legend
season 2 and that was when I was like
okay I could sort of replicate this
figure Wars and that unfortunately
didn't work out so then I had to just go
to the biggest game which is legal
legends and you're a reluctant
professional game yeah but I mean I I
mean it's a good choice obviously you
know it was
a bit arm so you like actively like
chase t-spawn yeah I was actively
chasing in sports I was pretty young so
um yeah so legally just I just was
forced there to just play obviously you
know the most money you could make was
from legal ourselves like I just got to
go there so um so I started at the end
of I was playing casually but started
playing more seriously to the end of
season 3 and you know I got challenger
in like a month
and like ranked 2 in another two weeks
so um yeah I basically just use my skill
set to and say anything about these
these guys up here will know really I'm
a bit of a new video extraordinaire so
they'll sort of like the fastest way out
who is there such a thing
yeah one of the few apart from arrival
that's always brought up 3-2 G but I'm
like 20 times better than trick2g so
that's not even a it's just a
straight-up fact so yeah and then I
basically sorta you know how do ya I
play it at the autumn regionals and then
I was part of Team Dignitas when they
came to us and then I was sort of you
know not so much kicked but I was sort
of a one-trick pony still from UTS I was
you really know how to jungle properly
so I mean ice then I founded my own team
and I was already three council most in
top ten of the solo queue so is easy for
me to get other players and I sort of
built the team and then just chalk the
name on it and those dials and got a
logo and yeah two years later we were
here now excellent all right before we
move on to Jake's he's doing he's got a
kind of a sense of how many people want
to ask questions just give us a hand up
I guess there is there a lot of people
it's like three people all right
actually before we answer questions can
we get some context in this room how
many people here follow OPR if you could
put your hand up all right so what who
else is here I don't
I pick up people here just cuz French
dragon mom cuz it interested in eSports
maybe we should have done that history
of eSports thing at the star that I
skipped through this is it the rut the
rails have come off you guys it's fine
okay do a bit more of a panel chat
before you go to questions because know
a lot of people wanting to ask questions
but um Jack you've got kind of
interesting history because you and I
hope I'm not stepping on any of your
anecdote but from what I you were
working in insurance you had like a
pretty good and successful career going
on and then you bailed to kind of work
at riot I'll tell you like you've heard
three successful stories so I'll tell
you my story which is rife with failure
so what happened is League of Legends
came out and I was going to university
to do biomedical science and I didn't go
at all so not even one class and I
played a lot of League of Legends and I
worked at McDonald's full time which was
great
keeping the dream alive yeah keeping the
dream so I thought you know what stuff
that take two so I went back to
University and I did a history and
literature and I did a dip head as well
so double major and I got two years into
that and I was playing and I wanted to
be a pro player so I was looking at
these guys and I'm like I'm gonna be a
pro player as well
so I got picked up by team it was
sequential back then and went on to be
frenetic array and we're on the North
American server still so huge ping I'm
talking we're playing on two hundred and
fifty feet so it's thing was the best
equalizer because I used to play maokai
which as everyone is aware doesn't
really require that much skill so
there's no one walking around on lease
in at this stage destroying me I'm just
playing maokai so I played a little bit
and then I found out I wasn't good
enough which was a little bit
heartbreaking so I stayed at University
and then you know Atlas was one of my
good friends from that and he asked me
to cast through the back of that a team
called the chief so asked me to coach I
coached two tournaments they're the only
two tournaments the chase have ever lost
so then I stopped doing that as well and
I was actually dropped out of university
for a second time as well so I didn't
finish any of that and I remember the
reason I dropped out of university was I
was reading a book it's called the
crying of lot 49 do not read it it's a
hundred fifty pages of torture and so
when I used to read books that I
couldn't actually get through because
I'm quick reader I'll run myself a bath
and I would read the book in the bath
and I dropped the book in his bar cuz I
fell asleep so I walk into my parents
room like in a towel with a soaking wet
book and I'm like I can't do this
anymore I'm dropping out and dad was
like alright you can go work in
insurance because he's an insurance
agent so shoehorned me into a corporate
gig so this is complete isn't it yeah
for a couple of years I was shoutcasting
at the same time and then I ended up
leaving that for right game so pretty
much the way you become a shoutcaster in
my opinion is be bad at everything else
you want to do it like virtually you
will find that one thing that you're
actually okay it's a process of
elimination
100% so I found out what I didn't want
to do and now I know what I do want to
do it was one of those things that in
all honesty I really want to be a pro
player and I hung around teams a lot I
spoke to a lot of people that were very
high level at the game and I could never
press buttons as well as them but I
thought I could think as well as them
and I can also talk so that's where she
are Carson kind of came into it for me
because it was just double play by play
back in the day I don't know if anyone
remembers it but the way a color caster
came around at least in Oceania was Papa
smithy used to play in tournaments
get eliminated really early and then
pastry time would make him sit on the
desk while pastry time yelled so it was
actually just an ex-pro player and using
the term very loosely like incredibly
loosely that is kind of how I got into
shoutcasting yeah I don't know if you
want to talk about sin from strangers
so feel free to chat me down there I
know I know for example you were very
committed to the game before you began
working it
one of things happens when you start
working it right is they tell you how
much money you've pumped into the game
yeah so right games is really good like
that they sit you down to the computer
it's something we called Dino vana you
know you wear a Teemo hat because that's
cool and they put you in a full glass
room it's like a fish tank and everyone
walks past and they can see than you
guys and they are let you know how much
you've spent on the game and when I was
working full-time I used to want to give
back because League of Legends was a
great community and I really did love it
so I used to put about fifty bucks a
week
Jenna walky is so it's been over three
thousand seven hundred bucks understand
that's a big back for example they used
to when I started we don't do this
anymore but we used to give unlocked
accounts and the guy looked at me and I
was like do you really want to use your
unlocked account on this one cause I
feel like you like 75% of the way there
just finish it off yourself we play like
players so we have to put money into it
as well but yeah that's what I was doing
beforehand all right well let's I think
moving on to questions so we're gonna
have we've got mics set up there and
there if you want to make their way to
those microphones to ask questions and I
found the best way to kind of make this
work we'll start with you sir but what
well the best way to make this work is
trying to introduce yourself then kind
of ask the question and also just sort
of either direct it to the whole panel
or just say who you're asking it to
start off with you know but what I am
interested in is how much mental health
is really interesting well let me start
with you Carla because I've spent some
time over a limited amount of time at
Legacy House and you guys actually have
a sports psychologist comes and works
with you right yeah so I personally take
mental and physical health extremely
seriously being a Health Sciences
graduate I think it also has a pretty
big impact on performance so how'd
legacy I do my very best to be able to
provide an environment where players
ultimately have the best tools to take
care of themselves
I'm not about I don't force people to do
anything I'm
forcing anyone to go to the gym I'm not
forcing and you want it to eat right but
the food I provide generally is healthy
I make gym access easily easy sorry and
we did we did our engage a sports like
this year to help us through some of the
mental things yeah I mean I mainly agree
with Tim there it's just physical and
mental health is just crucial to um to
performance as a player engaging so
sports psychology is an interesting one
because no one's really cracked every
North America it's sort of becoming more
popular now but I think that will
definitely save in the next couple of
years
like eSports you know psychologists and
sort of the the merge between
traditional sports and eSports but um
but yet to answer your question yeah
it's it's some really crucial to our any
player if you want if you want to play
the highest level yes and that's sort of
the way we're gonna crack you know that
international stage so um yeah I think
we already have yeah well yeah
technically is not really just beyond
that like even beyond playing I think
that physical and mental health is
important if you want to do anything at
the highest level so houses all go to
the gym together as well and uh the
biggest thing about a sports that I will
point out is it's not something that you
can't get injured in I've seen so many
players that have bad wrists
I mean Tim's been through it with tally
jatt who a lot of people know
internationally Joshua Chet Lisbon he's
one of the casters he's just had his
wrist completely reconstructed and had
to not play video games for nine months
he had tendonitis he had all of his
tendon shaved off and he's had to do
strength conditioning exercises to get
back into it because he used to play
like a dinosaur in his words so I think
that like a lot of the physical and
mental aspects of League of Legends are
important like across your whole life
like I don't think you can having to
neglect it especially mental I gotta say
I think mental is more important than
physical physical of course is important
but ultimately it's not it's a it's more
of a mental game than it is physical
think I think mental health is are
extremely poor yeah I was just going to
share an anecdote um so Tim mentioned it
before but back when they beat us in
2014 and then we proceeded to kind of
just stomp them afterwards I mean I'm a
tenant like that the boot camp yeah I
did yeah we didn't have a mid-laner oh
yeah okay anyway the what right did was
provide us with the sports psychologists
as well during that period and that was
probably actually the most constructive
time I remember being like the most
constructive like era of like two weeks
that we managed to have as like a team
and we got like a lot sorted out and we
progressed as I think like incredibly
quickly and since then we haven't
actually bring visited a sports
psychologist and we probably should but
um it was very very helpful and that's
what I can attest to I think and with
the physical side most of us go to the
gym we still have a few spaghetti arms
on the team but that's fine we're trying
to convert them I want to just share a
very very quick thing from my
perspective as well I the new FIFA came
out right and I played it for 13 hours
straight just grinding seasons because
I'm an idiot and I got up at the end and
tried to move my neck and couldn't and
then next I had to drive to Canberra to
do some stand-up gigs and so I was like
doing stand-up like it was it was [ __ ]
right and then so the next day I tried
to I was I was like I'm gonna go get a
massage done like to maybe blue sup the
muscles right and so I was very small
tilite he she's like oh how did you hurt
your neck and I freaked out and just
straight-up lied to her and I was like I
was playing basketball I play basketball
in 20 years I don't know I'm doing right
and then she's like she's like behind me
and like holding my shoulders and neck
and she goes oh really
usually this kind of injuries from too
much computer I was like oh I don't know
what you talking about sprung
anyway sorry thank you for the question
and I will move out into here so my
question is I've recently moved over
here
Europe and from what I understand that
you guys are a wild card League do you
guys ever feel that you're put down by
the other leagues because you're a wild
card League and look down upon everyone
because I feel like you guys are pretty
United on this front um I actually think
that's why wild card teams are able to
almost consistently take teams take
games off the teams at Worlds because
we're just kind of chronically
underestimated um so yeah yeah we just
saw like one of the sea-ice teams I just
take down a top Korean team well I mean
like INX like in most recent kind of
worlds yeah so and in speed EDG as well
and it's kind of really funny because as
a shot Costa having seen it firsthand
talking to the teams they kind of like
wild card became this slur where like I
meant second class where really what a
wild card means is like anything can
happen and that's why I mean actually so
fun to watch because like I didn't even
know what was going to happen and though
they're legitimate they're like I think
it was a miracle in one of his interview
was like if you don't know what you're
doing the enemy doesn't know what you're
doing that's his growth strategy he's
not saying that like he doesn't like
understand how to play the game it was
just like they had gone that deep into
the tournament that they didn't have a
game plan like Oh once we get to
quarterfinal we've hidden all these pigs
it was just like all right what's the
next thing that we know how to play
what's the next thing we know how to
play they're banning our brand okay
let's move on to Zyra let's move on to
this so they really did reclaim it as
like wild card is in like the blue shell
it just gets launched off Mario Kart
takes on out excellent thank you for
your question let's go to um so I'm just
curious how much time did you put into
games before you went professional I
mean Nathan he said he went gladiator
and Wow
I assumed that would have taken a very
long time well I mean obviously I was
still in school so I mean I I was
limited to the time you know we're
looking at four yeah and then say
weekends when you know it'd be like 24/7
so you know it was it was a lot of time
to
put into it obviously but um yeah I mean
there's nothing really else I could have
done homework but it's not fun so okay
I'll pass on this carbon never started
he's been playing video games cuz you're
quite a high flash players well right
yeah yeah before before we play before I
played like before I was a pro league
player sorry I mean I played League
I played League it's in season one I
think so I've been playing league for a
while so I played League I suppose for a
while before I was a professional player
I mean I had phases you know I am I
stopped playing for six months at one
point it was my Dre my grades were
slipping and then I got my grades back
up I was playing like eight hours of
normal games Saturday afternoon so it
for me it varied a lot yeah but it's
across across the board it is it takes a
lot of time to get you yeah absolutely
if your role is like as much time as we
could possibly fit in like I did other
things like work do martial arts and
stuff like that
but if I was at home like I was playing
video games yeah I mean I mean it's like
anything though you're putting the time
like obviously you know if you are
trying to get to the top level and
you're putting in you know half the
amount of someone else who's you know
working hard on you you know of course
you're gonna lose so yeah put in the
effort and apparently don't do that
absolutely do not do that that is not so
my question is directed towards anyone
on the panel with the oceaxe seen how it
is going into 2017 if you had to pick a
role in a sense have a be bot lane or
mid lane that has to be improved the
most coming into the next year what do
you think it would be so you're talking
in terms of Oceania so like the role in
general all-star I think top lane is
definitely the biggest one I think that
our top lane is currently
pretty far behind the other roles my
guess Armand and Tim can have their
opinion on their roles as well I
actually think CI like I can only really
talk from Goodling perspective but it's
actually really weird in Oceania and I'm
borrowing this from I think a spooks who
mentioned it to me as well and he said
that the way that I see so like you
makes you play because there aren't that
many good players is it makes you play
selfishly right and then that translates
like quite evidently into OPL games and
I actually think that's the biggest
thing that needs to shift it's not so
much that in like a new star player news
they're coming out it's that people kind
of across the board need to get better
and then like only then once like
everyone kind of like trusts each other
I'd like to an extent like that's when
like you see like everyone's play
elevated
you don't really like every role has
star players it's just everyone's just
inherently selfish so it's just
unfortunate yeah I wouldn't even pick
something on some of those or if I would
say our coaching staff just it's very
new and therefore very immature at the
moment so I'd say that the area that
like if I could pick one area to take us
like further internationally or anything
like that it would be leveling up you
know coaches analysts that kind of thing
I think our players are actually good
some of them are very young however but
I would say coaching stuff for me just
to ask you a question
I support I think not enough good
supports there are only a few I mean
even in OPL the depth is the depth isn't
very large I don't think and even less
so in soloqueue a lot of Jana mains
looking at you bryce outside that though
just to build on what um so I'm saying I
have to agree and I think particularly
applies to my role jungle if you look at
most junglers in the high solar key
ladder if for whatever reason your
spectating a high ELO challenger games
you know
I don't know why you would but if you
were you would see that most junglers
don't gank so much and they'll take all
the farm for themselves and try to take
all the kills and they'll try to carry
they'll try to hit level 16 before
everybody else in the game and then try
to 1v5 and the worst part about it is
that it works and this doesn't work in
competitive at all and so what you have
is you have a lot of people who are
considered good in solid queue who try
to make the transition to competitive
and just [ __ ] honestly so that's the
exact part that I took that TVs
described around thank you for the
question we've got about ten minutes
left and we've got about seven people to
get through so let's try and keep
answers in questions brief I apologize
in advance as someone who had a question
directed them and also an employee of
Riot Games so first thing yes I would
change it faker is the best player in
the world
smeb didn't do it I get a list as far as
a lot of changes in salary go so I would
actually be really interested to you
from the other guys because I'm very
biased I mean I worked on the other end
of the machine for a lot of it so I
don't know anything you're probably in
the best well I mean it's it's really
good like I mean the way I look at it
all the time you know is like so you
know you compare the other eSports like
right put the most investment into the
game so it's sort of you can't really
like you know I couldn't say it's bad
you know so it's obviously gonna happen
it's gonna better over the next couple
years but it's definitely the start at
the stepping-stone and next job is gonna
be you know but this time next year the
landscape is gonna look very differently
you know we could be looking at you know
players more moving into the you know
the five six figure salaries you know
pretty soon so I'm it's definitely a big
thing and it's something that you know
it's just gonna help push the scene
forward so um today it's definitely good
thing just very quickly I think the
biggest thing with
the increase in salaries is just pushing
more players to play full-time even
compared to other wildcard regions who
can playing full-time already for a few
years this really was the first year
that anyone who knows had done it and
only three teams did out of eight so I
think it's a huge step in the right
direction in terms of finally seeing a
no steamer at Worlds like I can't
disagree like money is good in the
history Norman elytis not performed how
much and when we do see people win and
do really well you try get them on
camera and it's like hey guys blow up
for us and you know you got static sort
of not really great personalities
winning big cups how much how much
importance do you guys put on a media
personality when it comes to media
training well I mean in terms of like
you can't really force it by if a
person's not funny you know you can't
force them to be funny right so I mean
it's sort of just like a like say tim's
like you know is the sort of person i
you know realiz you know typical
Australian careful careful I don't want
to do another side of it you know so see
I mean he's saying that Tim's not good
all right you're saying that that's what
you've been saying last hours so yeah
like it's it's just the thing that you
know you might get lucky some player
might have a really good person that
sort of shows off but I don't think it I
mean if if say a bronze spy I hadn't
even imagined personally you know they
don't a pro player right so it's sort of
just you know the pro players are gonna
be themselves and and I don't think you
should fabricate it at all I think it
should be real you know organic so um so
yeah it's um just something that we'll
see I want to jump on it as well a
little bit because I've got a rant
prepared for this one I think that a lot
of it comes from getting through
from you know some particular area of
the community as well I'll use Quinn for
example raise young ad carry firm the
Chiefs are great personality like really
bright kid is confident his ability
comes out says you know we're confident
going into this game they lose the game
and then all of a sudden these
twittering boxes full of you know very
very mean and I use that in the
strongest graphic graphic just not like
good and I think that somewhere along
the way this personality actually lost a
spark because I love seeing it you know
I love seeing the Allen Iverson's of the
sporting world you know yelling at his
teammates and talking about practice
everyone loves Kobe Bryant are these
players and you know even people like
Jason taco Madison the football used to
a head standing we can kiss the ground
but people thought it was funny right
and all of a sudden somewhere along the
way it became you know if this happens
and it does not go your way you get very
heavily flamed and I think that that is
a big thing that for a 17 year old kid
it's hard to deal with I had the same
thing last year when I went into Worlds
and I was like you know a TA or lgo day
like Monte Cristo picked LJ day to win
world's last year I picked eight I pick
SKT to win worlds and I got so much crap
about it
and I think the Korean team to win he
picked the Chinese team so I think that
yeah so I think I think the biggest
thing that you can do is you know when
people are willing to put themselves out
there and we still do have great
personalities that do it support them I
mean do something anyone can be an t
something it's actually really easy to
be an t something but they Pro something
support your teams get behind them
because that is that is the way the
personality actually comes out if you
like an advocate of it then more people
are going to want to do it more people
are gonna get good reactions because you
guys pro players do have great
personalities some of them are just [ __ ]
scared to show it on camera because they
get burned for thanks very much thanks
are you gonna pour Jack if you want I
will say also say very quickly if you
are someone who has good media training
but is terrible the game you can have my
job over the side
I have been just following eSports in
general for like 10 years or so and
Reese oh not recently but Riot Games has
made it so that you can't have a sister
team anymore how do you think that is I
in pacted the eSports scene for League
of Legends
so the clarification what the sister
team means is in the same league or in
in another Premier League so that is a
top league of the region you can't have
two teams with same ownerships for
example legacy can have an ATM in the
OTL and then a B team in the other OCS
but they can't have two legacies in the
OPL so I don't have a strong opinion on
this one you guys can take it but just
want to clarify yeah I mean I don't
really have we haven't really done that
Chiefs and legacy other ones with that
have the secondary teams arm so I can't
really you know have the experience
really it's a comment on that
see the problem is it's like like what
you what you're like you're leading to
is the because we're relatively in you
seen like the rule came in before our
scene was actually properly established
like before duck would like sister teams
could be implemented here so it hasn't
actually had much of like him adverse
effect on us because it never was a
thing in our region to begin with like
we could speculate about how it impacted
teams overseas in like I think it maybe
contributed a lot to the Korean Exodus
for example but at that point it's just
speculation can't really like help you
in your site yeah I mean to continue
speculating though I think I think it
helps eSports in general depending on
what your view of eSports is I think
sister teams creates kind of create a
system where for those who watched
worlds in 2014 yeah the to Samsung teams
were by far and away better than
everybody else and and that's because
they had you know great coaching
obviously great players as well but I
think having sister teams creates a
system where if your if your management
is real
good and you can buy up all the good
players and then you have those two
teams only scrim against each other it's
very easy to have extremely top-heavy
leagues and that's not really
interesting from a spectator point of
view but from a like it from a purist
League of Legends point of view I
suppose if you're interested in seeing
only the best games possible with
highest skilled players like I think the
removal assists of teams possibly heard
that but I think from the spectator view
in terms of like League excitement and
you know different teams succeeding I
think it helps great alright we are we
are really pressed for time right now so
we'll try to get to everyone but let's
try and keep these brief and I apologize
but what do you think of the most
important things to do to play
consistently in soloqueue that's good
let's keep this real quick down the line
one thing each what is the most
consistent thing to do to maintain
consistency in soloqueue for new players
by the same champion only depending on
your sleep schedule may be like if
you're playing your one game a day like
3 a.m. maybe don't I wake up I set an
alarm for 4:30 okay why back to be
critical but like maintaining a proper
mentality yeah that's fine I'm trying
not to tilt yeah yeah I was gonna say
like don't be toxic but I mean the
biggest thing the easiest way to improve
and learn is just to watch the pros and
you know go there's a bunch of YouTube
channels just Korean so like you
challenge are dime level just you know
look what they're building look at their
runes masteries there's a lot of tools
out there you know use them so yeah and
Jake do you have any advice for and
that's my advice I think that the
easiest way to get good at something is
to emulate you don't try and reinvent
the wheel like unfortunately your top
like a Peterik is not going to get you
to challenge up actually just emulate
what good players do oh that and then
then you want you monster that and what
you are and challenge it then you can
start figuring out what
like works for you but like people have
already solved this right there's like
heaps of guides out there so just
emulate great thank you for the question
all right let's rip through these ones
on the side of the cassette hey um so
there's been a bit of talk about on the
wave format recently so doublelift
obviously taking a break over the the
american spring and just him talking
about how ten or eleven month
competitive season is just too long
how'd you guys feel considering this is
your first you know tie year being
full-time competitors again just keep
Aaron says quick please yeah I don't
really want to comment on that because
we aren't wearing the team house or
anything like that but I mean it's sort
of like the burnout definitely exists um
is just sort of trying to work out a
manager it was just something that'll
take time I think that you know the TSM
schedule that sort of that they came
across was really incredibly and I was
so ridiculous but um you know I can see
why he made that decision a lot so the
problem in league of legends right now
is if you're not a top team you play for
six months of the year if you are a top
team you play in eleven months of the
year because all your players are voted
into all-stars all your team's go to
Worlds which is a month long and
everyone plays during the gap is split
one split two for MSI so what we are
trying to solve for is a system that
allows that to not be pigs and troughs
and for that to plateau out so then
there is more competition for mid and
lower tier LCS seems and wildcard teams
at the moment and then you know that the
top teams you know they still go to the
prestigious events but they don't have
to go to every event so that's kind of
how we're looking at it it's too many
for the top teams because eleven months
is too much one month break on anything
is gonna burn you out but for a team
that isn't like unicorns of love for
example they're only playing two three
month split which isn't all that much
when you think about it oh that's kind
of how we look at it excellent I thank
you for the question let's rip through
these last two because we are out of
time Adam from okay games come today
shuffles like what do you think now that
you know the major teams and oh so
getting team house what do you think the
next big step to closing the gap between
us and na and EU is we covered this
before when Jake mentioned
the levelling up coaching I think
support infrastructure would probably be
the next thing that you need to look at
because once you have an environment
when you can facilitate the players to
play to the best of their ability they
won't be able to hit that unless they
get the required support so that's
probably it I think playing overseas is
really important one of the big
disadvantages that we have here is that
we're not geographically close to
anything the other wildcard regions are
so if you look at like Turkey and Russia
they both play on a US Japan and see
both play on the other Asian servers
China Korea Taiwan I think Brazil and
that I am I think of the only ones who
play like us on their own regions I mean
but even latam could play on Brazil
which is a bigger region again we're the
only region that is truly alone and I
think I'm getting more teams
international and then bringing the last
question of the night thank you and I'm
just wanted to know what are you guys
personally what players do you look up
to the most like internationally that
you watch to learn from or even just for
fun watch some of their games mine was
always diamondprox early on he had kind
of invented camera jungling and I was
kind of amazed by that and I've always
always tried to kind of emulate that
that's who I wanted to play like but
recently I have to say Pengy I mean the
guy keeps coming back from the brink of
her time and I'm just putting on an
absolute show every time he's required
so he's been a star I think I mean I
think my answers pretty obvious I'm just
gonna say faker accent yeah like fake
faker pukes and are the two players that
I really look up to I think just because
they're pretty unsurpassed like like
they're almost flawless in what in what
they managed to do um crown now like I
saw I've started to like really look
into into him as well just because of
he's world he's worlds performance it's
just like what I really like value in a
player which is like play making and
consistency so yeah that's
those guys who got to yeah bjergsen for
me more is on the way he's like sort of
evolved and like build his brand and um
you know that sort of leadership role
that he has with tears have now looking
at for more you know a business
perspective you know he's built like one
of the biggest following he's like a
superstar right now in eSports so on you
know seeing him come from nothing two
years ago from copenhague was to TSM has
been a you know exciting transition to
sort of seem go I'm obviously you know
as some you know their stool almost a
flawless player so um so yeah it's
that's that's my pick yeah I'll give you
a caster because obviously I don't play
I look up did officio we both speak
English is our second language I speak
Australian he speaks Danish absolutely
nail that I got multiple tweets that
people could understand him more they
could understand me a world so that was
great they don't
in all honesty he's like a scholar of
the game he's probably the smartest
person like about League of Legends ever
he's and he's got really good teaching
skills he can break down pods and he won
takes everything and what I mean by that
is you watch a replay with this guy and
he like takes in like mini-map ward
positionings are set up as well as like
what's happening on the screen in one
and I'm like watching it like six times
so I can talk about on the analyst desk
he's guy just like flick said it once so
he is honestly and you know what's on my
team got to work within this time around
he's probably the best shoutcaster in
the world right now in my opinion right
all right well the last thing I would
like you guys to do is to give her an
applause and thank our panelists for
this evening
hey you guys so much
if you're hanging around I'm gonna come
me show a p.m. into one more 13 come you
know get some walls otherwise you guys
need me hanging around for a bit you
wanna chat people or yeah yeah we should
hang feel free otherwise I thank you
guys so much I think you do PacSun guys
with having us